I need to write this down because I
forget things sometimes and I think what
I heard today was important not to me
the time for me are almost anyone else
alive on earth today to make a
difference is past but someone somewhere
might be able to make something of this
or at least find it helpful or something
once I'm done I'm going to seal it up in
a pipe coat it in wax and chuck it into
the ravine maybe someday someone will
read this and try to put things together
if they're allowed to I'd love to start
at the beginning but I'm honestly not
sure when the world started to end could
have been years and years before the
final bits or it could have been all
once everything was just so grim
what with warmer air cooler seas too
little gas and too many people things
could have been unraveling for ages
before things bubbled up to the public
eye what I and others remember most was
women Disney magic sank and was then I
think that most people started to think
that things might be worse than they
seemed the Disney magic was a big cruise
ship one of those liner jobs it tools
around islands and stuff
one day news was screaming about how it
suddenly just went down when I was
trying to put into port the weird thing
about it was how there was no video of
it for such a long time
some still pictures of it floating fine
but none of it actually going down then
somehow a tape showed up and new started
playing it I have to imagine that they
didn't review it first the ship was
puffing along strong and fast the little
boats bobbing around it looking like
every vacation lovers dream when
suddenly it stopped
I mean stopped just hit a dead halt like
it just slammed into a mountain you
could see people go lurching forward all
over the deck a bunch of junk falls off
the sides a real mess it's all still for
a few seconds and then suddenly there's
this foaming behind the ship
most people assumed it was just the
engine trying to fire up again then the
arm came up I'm not sure if it actually
was an arm but it was some kind of limb
and it must have been a hundred feet
long at least it reached up along the
side of the boat and just ripped it open
I mean unzipped it like a coat you could
see all the people inside screaming and
running
it was awful then you saw something
lurched up a big spiny shape pushing
against that gap shoving in then there's
an explosion on its back and the camera
whipped up to show a couple of jets
whizzing by then it ended I just
remember sitting there stunned looking
at the television early noticing the
president coming on to declare state of
emergency I think it was two or three
days later when the tv went under full
government control maybe in a week I'm
not sure the internet got clamped later
but soon all I could hear read or see
was remain calm everything is under
control the oddest thing was that life
really didn't change much for a while
it'll still came still had to go to work
go to school and all that just a lot
more scared faces and a lot more weird
talk pretty soon we were getting told
whole towns were being evacuated that
there was a plague or a riot or a
terrorist bomb some other nightmare my
brother down south said that they got
moved because of some huge wildfire the
weird thing was he said that the fire
moved oddly seemed to shoot right for
gas or brush and didn't travel evenly
after a while he swore he saw would look
like a 20 foot tall man of fire walking
eating everything the call got dropped
right after he said that I haven't
talked to him since
so things got worse little by little
people kept being moved there is no real
way to communicate with each other
anymore that was really reliable so it
was hard to say just how bad things were
still word of mouth was still going
strong and it was creepy
crazy [ __ ] really stuff about zombies in
the north
killing frenzies in the east a place
near the ocean where the ground was
alive eating people occult screaming
about the second coming and killing
people that buy off God I started
pulling more and more away from people
just to get some ignorant peace of mind
looking back that probably saved my life
finally one day I woke up and there was
blood on my window it was outside and I
can hear some insane [ __ ] going down
outside screaming clanking gunshots and
smell like burning wires ahead I'm not
ashamed to admit it I left my fellow man
to rot and hid inside for almost a full
week long after the noise stopped after
the fifth day the electricity and gas
gave up along with the running water
when I finally got hard up for supplies
I poked my nose out and saw that the
whole west side of the world was gone
now I don't know for sure if it's
actually gone but there is a cliff that
starts 30 feet to the west of my house
and I cannot see the bottom of it I also
can't see the other side of this ravine
so for all intents and purposes that
part of the world has gone for me suburb
I was in look like a war zone
blood broken stuff everywhere
how is this carved up no bodies though
which I still think was weird
i scrounged up some food and stuff from
some of the houses then went back home
I've been doing that for a while now I'm
not sure how long really might have been
years and years are just a few months
it's hard to say sometimes the Sun just
sticks in one spot for what feels like
days other times these clouds roll in
and you can't see two feet
there's things around - I run it the
first noise but I think they're of a
man's size that they seem to like metal
other little things scramble around and
the rebel sometimes so I try to keep
clear one time a thing that looked like
a pill bug the size of a cat crawled out
looked at me and screen stopped in
perfect English I hid inside for days
there are also these big blimp things
that's float around sometimes they have
little bug legs on their undersides they
look kind of like maggots with my eyes
all over they eat everything when they
are land but most of the time they stay
up high one of these you just pass when
I found the hurt guy he was all ripped
up and looked like one of those SWAT
team guys you see on TV sometimes but
his combat suit thing was ripped to hell
I dragged him back home and then we
talked he said that he'd been hunting
the blimp thing but had gotten attacked
he wouldn't say by what but he looked
like he was on his last legs
I fed him some canned beans and some
water and he seemed to come around a
little he asked me who I was and was I
all right and all that he seemed kind of
shocked when I said he was the first
person I'd seen since the west of the
world vanished he told me it wasn't gone
just relocated but wouldn't say what
that meant
I helped heal him up and kept asking who
he was but he wouldn't say finally he
said screw it and then his orders were
probably no good anymore anyway and he
told me he said he worked for a
foundation or something
that they were like a culmination jail
and Research Center he said that he was
one of the agents who went around trying
to find strange stuff and keep it from
hurting people I said he was doing a
hell of a job so far
he laughed pretty hard he said something
had happened and then a bunch of these
things that God loose at the same time
and caused this fundation place to lose
control he said it became a GH - zero
dead greenhouse scenario I asked him
what that meant and he looked at me for
a while before going on he said that's
what they call a situation where
everybody in earth dies but the earth
itself is still okay and can support
life I asked what did that matter if
everybody's dead and he smiled strangely
I asked him if anyone else on earth was
alive and he said yes but carefully
spread out and contained after that I
just sort of sat and digested things for
a bit and then the man started
stretching and checking his cuts he was
starting to pull his boots on him
I asked what happens now and he said
they may have to reboot things said they
had the technology to recreate almost
anything and that making people is
actually pretty easy said that they
would clean out and contain things where
he built broken cities and repopulate
them it would take a long long time he
said they would eventually get things
back to the way they were before even
said that they could recreate memories
and stuff right this Sat kind of stunned
and watched him as he just kept going
getting dressed like this was all no big
deal I told him he was nuts and there's
no way people would just forget this
could all be just swept away
he stopped looked at me smiled and then
said why not it's been done before I
don't know if that man was crazy or not
I think he was saying as he was leaving
he said something about putting my house
under water please don't let them brush
me away don't let them hide us try and
find more I know there's got to be more
people who try to leave something behind
don't let the world die in vain remember
us
you
all right maggots you know the drill
facebook-dot-com forward-slash the
Volgin and over to that sucker and click
the like button if you haven't already
and if you have Oh buy a beer someday
all right tan